then eventually got to his his big body
and we took that out the bin and we put
him on the floor and then it's a case of
recovering all the evidence that you can
so you're considering things like hairs
fibers skin flakes all this kind of
Chase evidence or biological evidence
that could link him back to a place or
to a person
[Music]
when I was 12 I watched a TV program
and it was about a farmer who had
murdered his wife he then attacked
himself with a knife to make it look
like it had been a robbery gone wrong
but you had forensic scientists going in
and they looked at the blood patterns
the way the blood was in the house they
looked at the injuries on his body and
they basically said there's no way that
this has been somebody that's coming and
done this to him he's done this himself
look at the way the blood's distributed
around the house and basically they just
debunked his whole story
and I just sat and watched it and
thought Oh my God that's what I wanted
to do and and that was it from that
point went to university did a biology
degree and then went on and did a
master's degree in forensic science and
what kind of things are they teaching
you at Uni you learn about blood pattern
analysis you learn about DNA profiling
all the different kinds of forensic
science and then eventually you focus on
the part you want to do which for me was
biology so I got to go and see autopsies
I got to see actual casework being done
in the laboratory which was a brilliant
experience to be able to bring back and
then put into my own job and it'd
eventually start my career so what is
the difference between forensic
scientists and like crime scene
investigation or is that like the
practical application of
so the difference probably depends on
where you work in Scotland we have a
model which we call Crime Scene to court
model so as a forensic scientist I
attend crime scenes I do the follow-up
work in the laboratory and then I go to
court and explain the evidence to court
so I would attend serious claim for
example and explain death's murder
series sexual crimes so in my role I
span everything from crime scene right
through to court however there were some
people who concentrate on crime scene
only in some people who are lab-based
and it really depends on what your role
is and the crown type you're working on
in our organization we also do
ballistics which is investigation of
firearms we do chemistry which looks
into fires tool marks Footwear marks
there's also document and handwriting
there's forensic science behind
controlled drugs and toxicology drug
driving drink driving so it's a massive
massive area
forensic basically means for the court
so you'd apply in science to the court
biology is my area of science but
there's lots of other areas of science
that are equally as applicable just a
different kind of case study
what was your first case
exactly but I'll never forget the first
thing I examined so when when you're at
Uni you learn how to look for blood to
learn how to look for body fluids and
basically you've got clothing that
somebody's dropped a bit of blood on and
it's nice clothing that's brought a
charity shop or donated by people at the
uni first case I examine the clothing of
a homeless man
picked up his trousers and out the
bottom of his chosen leg fell
a Joby as we would say in Scotland so
it's a very steep learning curve um as a
forensic scientist you start going to
crime scenes you look at clothing it's a
different world to what you grew up and
thankfully and it's a very very steep
learning learning curve but I will never
forget that as a first item examined as
a real life forensic scientist but you
were doing blood bladder analysis too
and stuff what was the blood or what was
the blood that was being splattered at
University so at University you you do
blood spatter analysis training so you
just put paper all around the room we
have horse blood
or sometimes you'll use pretend blood
and your Baseline just throw it about do
different things just to look how blood
behaves and that is you you're training
in one particular case
and women have been found dead in the
bathroom of her boyfriend's flat and the
boyfriend said she had fallen off the
toilet and had some kind of fit and that
had caused blood patterns but the way
the blood was radiating upwards
we believed was because she had been
struck when she was lying on the ground
and that is why the blood would go
upwards if she'd been having a fit the
blood would have gone outwards so we
recreated this in the toilets at work
with a turnip and a pool of blood and
although it's not ideal it still gives
you an idea of how the blood would
behave can you remember the first time
you saw a body in the field
um the first time I saw a body was
actually when I was a student doing my
placement for my Master's Degree I was
in America
and the director of the lab thought it
was important that I experienced that
side of the job and the first body I
ever saw was a three-month-old baby a
sudden infant death baby I was 23.
um I was thousands of miles away from
home and that was the first dead body I
ever saw the first post-mortem I ever
saw
um
and I just remember going home from that
and sitting in the room where I was
staying and waiting on the time
difference being right so I could phone
my mum because I just wanted to speak to
my family and that's the first time I
saw a dead body
um at work the first time I saw a dead
body was again a postmortem
back in the day
when you started in the lab they kind of
wanted to test that you had what it took
to deal with that kind of thing so we
got taken to the mortuary and you got
Stood Beside the postmortem table so you
went behind glass you got all the sights
and the smells and you watched a
postmortem from beginning to end and
that was really I think their way of
testing if you were able to to cope with
this and how you would deal with the
pressure of seeing someone data close
it's not until you go home that you
start to think I've just seen a dead
person and and that's when it hits home
and that's what I learned very early on
in my career is
you can't let that voice take over you
can't focus too much on that side of
things or you would take too much of
your job home with you
what was the biggest case you worked on
probably the first case that got the
most media attention was the murder of
Angelica clique
and that was a murder of a Polish
student in Glasgow so Angelica's body
was found underneath the church in the
center of Glasgow she'd be missing for
several days my involvement was to look
at her body recover any forensic
evidence from her body and that was done
underneath the floorboards beside her so
the Angelica crime scene was quite
difficult in that she was found
underneath the floorboards her body was
directly underneath a trap door in the
floor
and that chapter was bisected by uh beam
a supporting Beam for the floor
so the difficulty is that I wanted to
examine their body where she lay
from looking at the crime scene pictures
it was apparent this was going to be
essentially motivated crime the flyover
trousers was undone there's quite a lot
of blood on our hands and as soon as you
move a body that is bleeding or a body
that has any other body fluids
then you could start redistributing that
body fluid and that potentially can
destroy any forensic evidence and it can
also mean you might not be able to Give
opinions about how your body fluid was
distributed for example semen inside the
body
so I wanted to examine our fear Chile
to do that I needed to go down the trap
door now the trap door was Tiny because
it was bisected with this wooden beam so
first of all we thought well we'll cut
the wooden beam and make the trapdoor a
little bit bigger but by cutting the
wooden beam immediately you're going to
contaminate The Climb scene underneath
there's also health and safety risk as
well you're cutting a big beam from a
very very old wooden floor it could be
potentially very dangerous we talked
about cutting an area of the floor
further away and crawling along to where
her body was but again health and safety
wise
we don't want to do that so in the end
the decision was made that I would just
try and squeeze down this trapdoor and
see if I could fit and would take it
from there so that's what we did so the
first step is to recover any evidence
round about the opening to the trapdoor
because Angelica's body has gone down
there but we don't know at that point if
the murderer has gone down there as well
so we recovered all the evidence from
the trapdoor
and then I wriggled down the space of
the trapdoor underneath the floorboards
so I could then recover any evidence
from Angelica's body and then did the
follow-up work in the laboratory and
then eventually presented that evidence
in court and it led to Peter Tobin being
jailed and he was then established to be
a serial killer and he was convicted of
murdering two other young girls
um who had actually been missing for I
think at that point nearly 20 years
so that became massive
what's been the worst thing that you've
seen in your work
wow
um as you know a lot of horrible stuff
um I think that the obvious one would be
um the rape and murder of a young boy
who had been raped and murdered by a
convicted pedophile and put down a bin
shoot
so that investigation
um
Louis boy was in the bin
and we had to recover his body from the
bin and which is a painstaking process
when you arrive at a crime scene
probably your natural instinct is to go
straight to the body and start
recovering the evidence but in this case
he was in the bin and there's a lot of
rubbish on top of his his little body so
we had to recover everything
methodically from the bin because there
could be anything in there that could be
evidence it could be weapons it could be
the accused clothing so everything has
to be recovered and recorded very
methodically
then eventually got to his his b body
and we took that out the bin and we put
him on the floor of the bin shed he was
in and then it's a case of recovering
all the evidence that you can so you're
recovering anything that is going to be
a trace of evidence from whoever's
killed him or wherever he was killed so
you're considering things like hairs
fibers skin flakes Trace Amounts of
paint and DNA body fluids
all this kind of treats the evidence or
biological evidence that could link him
back to a police or to a person so it's
just a case of very methodically working
in a team with a pathologist with the
photographers who are recording it and
with the police to recover everything
methodically so that if you go down to
court further down the line everything
is recorded properly
does it have an emotional impact on you
yeah I'd say every crime scene you go to
has an emotional impact on you
um
I could probably close my eyes and
imagine every crime scene I've been at
you can picture it you can recall it
very clearly it has an emotional impact
on you it's been able to switch that off
when you go home and I guess being able
to
compartmentalize that at a certain
extent so it doesn't take over your life
so you can actually learn to cope with
it
being at any time you've ever been
scared at work like you're investing in
a serial killer there at one point it's
like do you ever feel of fear yeah
there's times in my work when I have
felt scared I mean I felt scared going
into this trapdoor I mean there's times
I've gone home and I've lean awake and
I've not been able to get to sleep for
hours and you're relaying over and over
in your head but a lot of that time what
you're going through in your head is
have I done that right have I done
everything I possibly can have I
collected all the evidence I can there's
a lot of pressure on a scientist that
has seen to get written right first time
because you don't usually have you don't
have a second shot at it you've got to
go and get everything
how I cope with it is I would go into
work and speak about it with colleagues
colleagues that had been to something
similar colleagues who could completely
empathize and understand with what
you've seen
and that's what we all do we'll sit down
with each other and we'll talk to each
other and
my organization is incredibly supportive
there's there's a lot of help and a lot
of support so these things do start to
get on top of you if you feel you're not
coping and there's a massive amount of
support but for me it's always been
talking to a fellow colleague
and obviously your jobs
trade a lot in Media there's a lot of TV
shows that have
what are the most common mistakes that
those shows make
so
yeah when they go in and they just shine
a light and all the blood to just glows
and it's really easy to find you know
the hours I have spent on a dark carpet
with a torch looking for blood whereas
the on the TV it's very easy it just it
just glows I think the other thing is a
forensic scientist Works in a team
it's a massive Team game a forensic
scientist doesn't speak to the suspect
doesn't carry out interviews doesn't
speak to the family and I think the tv
shows will portray this forensic
scientist as someone who's carrying a
gun and they're walking about and
they're interviewing people and chasing
people down the street that doesn't
happen we have a small part to play
as part of a much bigger team and a
bigger investigation and that is our
part our part to go and gather the
evidence look at the evidence in the lab
and take that evidence to court that's
it when you interpret DNA profiles
there's a lot of desk work a lot of
thinking time so you're not always out
of clansing with dead bodies or in a
laboratory messing about the chemicals
and looking at dirty clothes in a nice
whatever A lot of it is desk based and
thinking interpreting reporting and I
don't think that's ever portrayed DNA of
evidence started in like the 80s and 90s
and that was a big revolution in the
kind of world of forensic investigations
is there anything that could happen
again like that do you think another
step forward in the next 20 years yes so
DNA was a massive thing in that it can
give you a DNA profile from a tiny
amount of material you can search on a
database it's a fantastic tool
the biggest thing that will change
forensic science going forward and we're
not that far away from is being able to
see this DNA could have come from this
person and this DNA has come from skin
cells or it's come from vaginal material
and actually
tell you the source of the the DNA at
the moment you can do chemical tests so
you can see that that's a blood stain
that's the stamenstain you could obtain
DNA from it so you can give an opinion
the DNA is from this body fluid but
there's a lot of times you can't see
what the DNA came from how long it's
been there have it got there
so for example if you've got a sex
offense case and you've got the victims
daily in the person's hands you couldn't
say that was a vaginal material but a
test that can tell you the source of the
the cell then that would be massive and
a lot of these types of cases so being
able to actually pinpoint
the the source of the DNA is a big thing
and it's also going to become faster I
think we'll get to a point where you can
actually add a crime scene get blood and
be able to get all the information from
the blood of the crime scene instead of
going away to lab and waiting a couple
of days so the technology is becoming
faster more sensitive and soon it's
going to give us a lot more information
as well also there's a lot of DNA work
being done to be able to actually say
that this is their profile but they
would have discolored eyes that here
would have been that color this is what
they would have looked like all that
work is all bubbling at the end of the
surface and we're constantly constantly
improving the DNA and DNA has
only been in regular use in forensic
science for just over 20 years and the
amount that has come on in those 20 odd
years is incredible so where it will be
in 20 years from now is is really
exciting
it's these are must be very hard things
to go to why do you do the job what's
the satisfaction you got out of it
I guess you can't undo what's happened
but you can stop that person doing that
to someone else and also I guess it
gives people closure whatever that word
means
um you can give the families an answer
um
and that's rewarding that's very
rewarding the work that I was involved
in
on Angelica's murder
is fantastic because
it led to further investigations that
led to the discovery of the bodies of
two young women which gave their family
answers so being involved in that case
was a massive thing in my career and
that's something that I look back on and
and I am proud of it
but
I just think everything you know every
time you do a bit of work and you get a
good result and and somebody gets an
answer then you know everything I think
I'm just really grateful that I I do
have this job and I'm involved in this
kind of work
[Music]
foreign
400 different scenes where people have
disemboweled themselves put a knife in
their stomach and and kept themselves
open while they're alive even one
gentleman decided to take some scissors
and cut his intestines while he'd done
it and throw them in the bath